please welcome Robin William
animation means to breathe life into
something experts use our magic to
create the image of something that is
vibrant and alive men know it better as
viagra there's Clint going not me
there's the opposite of Botox animated
characters are becoming more and more
expressive and animated and alive unlike
Joan Rivers and many of the women in
Beverly Hills who have that expression
of constant surprise and you say then
they go what are these lumps under my
eyes I go those are your nipples madam
also they tell me now that spongebob is
gay SquarePants is not gay tight pants
maybe spongebob hot pants you go girl
what about Dunn luck little sailor top
no pants hello
Chippendale two male monks sharing a
trunk and coveting nuts hello
Bugs Bunny in more dresses than J Edgar
Hoover Mardi Gras hello what are we
talking about and also part of animation
is voices this year Marty Scorsese plays
a Blowfish it's really good he's gonna
take a bow fish you know it's a great
boyfriend Charlotte Bob De Niro was a
shark not a big stretch I was good I'm
good I'm good
Brando could have been Elmer Fudd he
would have been amazing be very very
quiet
I'm hunting rabbit and Elmer Fudd could
have been a streetcar named desire
Stella but the guy who I want to see do
a voice I want to see Jack Nicholson his
Bugs Bunny going hello Doctor
what's up nice piece of tail Trixie and
now ladies and gentlemen the nominees
are the cream of this year's crop of
animated features are the Incredibles
Bradford shark tail filled the mask you
trek to Andrew Adamson